I've heard you mention you know multiple
times about marriage being a bad
proposition for men yeah and I really
kind of want to dive into that because I
I feel like I talked to Elliot Hulse
about this we're like not you're correct
and only three percent of the population
Waits 97 of people do not wait to have
sex until marriage women
though a lot of men are virgins even
into their 30s still right okay actually
that that's that's the study I read must
have been for women I did not did not
know that but I guess with the 80 of the
the men not having sex that would make
sense
um
you know there's a lot of guys that are
in their 30s right now I think the data
says something like 30 of men up to the
age of uh 30 or 33 are not having sex
I think they're making it to the wedding
night as virgins though because aren't
they sleeping with the girl while
they're dating they might they might get
lucky and get you know
um a short-term girlfriend or they might
get you know one girl you know sort of
under the Belt have a little bit of
experience but the vast majority of men
today are actually sexless like they're
they're not having good results with
women they're not even dating
um there's a large community of men out
there
um they're called black pillars in cells
um and they get together and they spend
a lot of time online they make a lot of
videos they have discussion forums and
they talk about how they were dealt a
terrible hand their jaw structure is not
right they're not tall enough their skin
color is wrong they just sort of like
there's a lot of whinging and whining
it's very similar to the victim mindset
that feminists use except for they're
just saying like you know it's not fair
and why can't women just see me you know
for what I am because I'm a really nice
guy sort of thing and it's like well if
you're 300 pounds and living in your
mom's basement playing video games with
a neckbeard there's not a lot of women
and they're gonna you know want to chase
you down my friend yeah
so I guess what I wanted to go with that
was you know like you you say marriage
is a bad proposition for men I
definitely think in the climate that
we're living in I you know there's truth
in that but what I feel like is is the
pro the problem stems from the fact that
if people aren't waiting they're not
committed to waiting men or women
like so you were married and you were
divorced now did you have sex before
marriage of course yeah okay most people
do right and and everybody says you know
you got to take a car for a test drive
right everybody that's the number one
argument people give back to me when I
talk about waiting but I'm like if that
works so well why is the divorce rate 50
well that's what everybody's doing you
know so my thought and my belief heavily
based on my own experience this is
really kind of what my book is all about
was I used to be the biggest man [ __ ]
in Baltimore I have sex with hundreds of
women hundreds of the biggest men who
are in Baltimore yeah man I was well
known too okay and um I was a stripper
and I was a nightclub promoter and I
just had tons of casual sex and then I
became a Christian I had this radical
Encounter With Jesus when I was 27. and
selfishly I believe that if I didn't sin
long enough I knew what I was signing up
for when I followed I mean I know that
you know monogamy is basically what I
was signing up for and I was willing to
do it but and I thought well if I don't
sin long enough God will give me a wife
I'd never been in love and I felt like
you know if I behaved myself he would
give me a wife and I didn't think it was
going to be long and it turned into six
years of abstinence and then I backslid
is what they call it I don't know if
you're a Christian but I basically went
out started having sex again and had a
bunch more sex hun you know a bunch more
women and then rededicated my life and
somewhere in there from living at the
polar ends of the spectrum back and
forth I really started to understand
like why I kept getting into these
relationships with these women that were
there was never it was lackluster of
every relationship wasn't that great
because I wasn't asking myself the hard
questions on the front end so now I've
been outside of two isolated mistakes
I've been abstaining from sex for 11
years and imagine it's pretty tough
um and I could get sex if I wanted
anytime and um but I can look at a woman
now and say see everything you want is
she your best yes before I was having
sex on the front I wasn't thinking about
my best yes I was like she's hot you
know take her out gonna have sex sooner
or later
and then I would end up drifting into
relationships with these women some of
them not all of them but some of them
and like you said men complicate their
lives and then they justify and that's
exactly what you know I'd be in these
lackluster relationships that I would
stay in with with women that you know
arguing all the time or lots of problems
and I would stay in these relationships
because that's what the biology of the
sex does a woman pair bonds to a man
even if it even if he's one foot in and
one foot out he might be even sleeping
with other women and she's gonna you
know stand by her man and then the man
feels a sense of ownership over the
woman doesn't want other guys to bang
her even if he wants other you know even
if he wants to date or sleep with other
women or even if she's a complete [ __ ]
and people get these soul ties is what
they call it in christianese and they
spend their whole lives with the wrong
people and I believe it all goes back to
the fact that you didn't do it God's way
he didn't wait so now now this is what
you get how do you feel about that
um yeah that's interesting I mean I'm
not a religious guy so I don't subscribe
to any
um organized religion and
um I don't think humans are great at
monogamy you know if we're being honest
I don't I don't believe that we were I
mean evolutionarily speaking and again
you know I'm coming at this from a
different angle you know from you
obviously but from that perspective
um we never operated as monogamous pair
bonders we were nomadic uh
hunter-gatherers uh there was lots of
promiscuous sex it's kind of always been
that way
I think that
um religion can be a good buffer I mean
if you want to invite a woman in your
life I would say a woman that subscribes
to a religion that
um
you know is good for the Family
household for the household unit for uh
children
um you know for her pair bonding to you
to looking up to you to letting you lead
um you know and encouraging the man to
lead obviously
that could be a good thing
um so I'm not opposed to it like my kid
goes to a Catholic School obviously
right so I don't have issues with it but
I don't I don't like a lot of the the
Trad con sort of narratives that uh push
guys into marriage blindly I think that
you have to open your eyes to the
reality of what marriage is you have to
recognize that in most places in the
west if you get married you are
essentially inviting the state into your
household
um the state is built in such a way that
it actually encourages women to get
divorced like women are financially
incentivized today to leave their
families to leave their husband because
they will make a lot more money uh from
the government as a single mom raising
the kids having most of the control
raising those kids uh and alienating the
father from those kids like there's
Financial incentives to breaking up the
household so I have an entire chapter in
my book on why smart men don't marry I
don't know if you've read my book yet
now I've read The Cliff Notes yeah okay
so it's probably worth checking out I
mean you're not going to agree with all
of it obviously but I think you'll get
some insight from my perspective
especially on things like marriage and
you know a few other
um ideas in there but I think that if
you're gonna get married you need to vet
women properly
um it's not on the table for me like
without question I would never get
married again right I'm in a long-term
relationship I got a great gal you know
she's my girlfriend uh you know we've
been together for a while we're
monogamous
um but I would never get married I mean
if she said if you know if you don't
marry me then I'm gonna leave I would
just say okay fine bye right
I would have to be okay with that
because I'm not that that guy that would
allow the state to govern what happens
in my household right um now there's
things that you can do to mitigate those
risks or minimize them there's states
that you can move to that are uh equal
or father friendly like Kentucky for
example Arizona they're right at the top
of the list
um you know you can vet for red flags
you can make sure she's got a low Notch
count or no Notch count there's a lot of
things that you can do but by the time
you do all of those things
um you're probably left with less than
one or two percent of the female
population and then you have to you know
consider well okay if in that dating
demographic there's only one or two
percent of the women you know available
to me
um how many of them am I actually going
to be attractive enough to that they're
going to see me as their hypergamous
best option they're going to see me as
their Apex alpha male and want to be
with me sort of thing so
um it's a difficult proposition and even
if you layer it with you know protective
measures even if you want to get a
prenup you know if that's your thing
women always reserve the right to change
their mind at any given time I've talked
to lots of guys during my consults
because one of the things that I did a
lot of coaching on was guys going
through the divorce grinder in fact a
lot of the data that's in my book comes
from many of my consoles too and I
remember talking to several guys that
were like you know she came from a good
family the parents were intact the
siblings were all intact uh good
Christian lives went to church every
weekend
um you know conservative always voted
you know conservative from a red state
all of those things ticked off all the
boxes but then he's like but then she
started working in HR in this woke
Corporation cut her hair short got fat
dyed her hair purple got some weird
tattoos and now we're getting divorced
and I don't recognize her and she's
taking the kids and she won't let me see
them and it's like that story didn't
happen just once like I like I saw
versions of that movie many many times
over and over again so one of the things
that you have to understand as a guy is
if you do invite a woman your life on a
long-term basis and you and you create a
family with her she always reserves the
right to change her mind at any given
time one of the big
um
demographic categories for guys today
are these dudes that they are uh they
call themselves the passport Bros I
don't know if you heard about these guys
where they figure that you know Western
women's minds are polluted with toxic
feminism so they're better off getting a
gal from Latin America from Asia from
Eastern Europe or something like that
and they fail to recognize that if you
bring a woman from one of those
countries to the West the West will
pollute their mind over time eventually
right because everything in media
marketing advertising government it's
all about you know women are oppressed
men are oppressors BLM you know like you
go right down the list of all the stuff
there's rainbow flags and square flags
and all these flags everywhere there's
Pride months for this and that the other
thing they're going to start to hear all
of these narratives and you're going to
have to have really good frame to
maintain that long-term relationship and
only an unplugged Alpha's got Great
Frame right most guys are plugged in
beta mail so they think that they solve
the problem by bringing somebody from
another country over but the room
reality of it is they end up getting
destroyed over time yeah most of them
anyway yeah I definitely heard you talk
a lot about the family law and I agree
with it I mean there's I even think
about like you know single moms getting
more money from welfare if they have
more kids out of wedlock like there's so
many laws that are just completely
contrary to what we're trying to
accomplish here and exactly it's almost
like well what you're trying to
accomplish is different from the agenda
that they are trying to
you know cram down everybody's throat
like it like it seems clear to me anyway
that their agenda is the pussification
of the West they don't want strong
virtuous males leading the household
they want the government at the head of
the household they want women thinking
that they're victims right so you know
when you start to look at all these
narratives and you start to dive real
deep down the rabbit hole like you start
to realize well
ooh this is a pretty messy environment
right and it's like I'm kind of the guy
now that's more of the enjoy the decline
like you know with my stuff my my
content my videos I like to just take a
big map and I'll be like okay here's all
the landmines on the map so just don't
step in them you know sort of thing and
you should be good yeah um so that's how
I tend to operate now it's like some
people say it's Doom and Gloom some
people say well it's just accepting the
world for what it is and it's just the
reality of things and I kind of lean on
the ladder because that's my style
um but I got a great relationship my
life's amazing I got Amazing Friends
Business is great so
um you know I think that my uh results
at least speak for themselves in that
sense yeah you're a realist I guess
where I'm trying to go with it is I
guess I'm trying to get an ideal list
where I'm like if everybody and I know
this will never happen but if I could
convince everybody to wait right then
you got a world full of people that are
saying their best yes women they're
married no they're not going to marry
these virgins because a lot of people
yeah aren't virgins right now that but
they would still stop and they would
have to choose their best yes and that
would create uh a lot more successful
relationship than just drifting into
something you know when you're yeah I
love that notion I wish that notion was
true but I mean like how do you fight
the woke Narrative of like the Main
Street like you know even in popular
culture and music like when I was a kid
the music that I would listen to was
like you know metallic uh kiss Twisted
Sister poison warrant you know Guns and
Roses like those were cool bands that
that had an interesting message and a
lot of it would you know if listen to
the lyrics especially in the ballads
like there were a lot of just you know
love her and she broke your heart and
you'll get over and don't be a sucks
sort of thing but you know today's pop
culture is you know you get artists like
little Naz who are twerking on the devil
yeah and it's just like homosexual you
know and that's normal right like I
can't go somewhere now
but a lot of language you know we can't
use today
the r word the t word like all these
words are now like the initial word
right like I was driving the other day
and there was a [ __ ] across the road
and I I still use the term training not
transsexual because to me [ __ ] is
short for transsexual walking across the
street my daughter's in the car say get
a load of the [ __ ] over there you
can't say that that's not politically
correct I'm like are you kidding me like
like this is where we are today this is
what school this and you know Catholic
School right you know this is what
Society this is what culture this is
what screens have like taught our our
children now even at these young age
like you can't use these words because
it's offensive it's gonna hurts that's
that's weird okay like that was weird
when I was a kid but today it's like oh
you have to embrace it you know you have
to bring it in your life you know they
send these uh drag queens to schools and
libraries in the public school system to
read to small children like that's
disgusting
yeah but that's just the way that I see
things so it's like you know your point
like I love the idea like I wish the
world was that way but the Grim reality
of the of the situation is it's it's
it's it's not yeah and it's and it's a
weird and dangerous place and I think
that you know if you're gonna have a
family and you want to have kids find
the right gal make sure you know make
sure you've vetted her properly I would
get the hell out of an urban center city
center especially like the left-leaning
liberal ones get out in the damn country
yeah you know grow grow as much as your
food as you can keep that woke crap away
from your kids homeschool them you know
as long as you can you know people say
well homeschool kids are weird no kids
that go to the public system are a lot
weirder than the homeschool kids that I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out